okay so we're continuing our sort of uh
tour through
the modern april 2021
republican party as it may be we already
looked at an interview with a republican
trump supporter a republican donor who
attended this
very strange event in florida over the
weekend
it was an individual who is experiencing
completely unhinged
delusions and has fallen for baseless
conspiracy theories and is very very
secure
in those beliefs so that was that was a
trump supporter
republican donor now let's look at a
little bit of what donald trump said
during his speech to these republican
donors because
if they are to continue their loyalty to
him that we've seen so far
and and the things trump said are the
things that continue being said heading
into 2022
could be an absolute bloodbath for the
republican party and in essence donald
trump's
statements to republican donors over the
weekend can be summarized as
lies conspiracy theories
and absolutely vitriolic rants
including against his own fellow
republicans and that's what makes this
absolutely fascinating for example
donald trump
went on the attack over the weekend
against former republican senate
majority leader
now senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell with the new york times
reporting that donald trump said the
following things and more
quote did he ever say thank you to me
talking about mcconnell
no i hired his wife referring to elaine
chao
mitch mcconnell's wife did he ever say
thank you to me
no trump adding that quote a real leader
would not have accepted the result of
the 2020 election
and trump also reportedly according to
three people in the room
referring to mitch mcconnell as a quote
dumb
son of a [ __ ] when trump attacked mitch
mcconnell
the reports are that the room of
republicans really liked it and were
loudly cheering
interesting but what does that mean for
republicans in 2022
trump also went after his own former
vice president mike pence
trump saying to the room full of donors
pence should have had
quote the courage to refuse to certify
the results
understand that trump's gripes with
mcconnell and pence
were that they seemingly realized joe
biden won
and did not humiliate themselves above
and beyond what they did do
in order to try to make that case trump
continued
over the weekend to spread election lies
even telling specific lies about the
results of the 2020 election in
particular
states and said that generally the
entire election was quote
rigged earlier in the show we talked
about how
the republican party voters currently
trust trump on medical issues more than
they trust dr fauci and the cdc one of
the things trump did over the weekend
was go after dr anthony fauci
the crowd reportedly loved that applause
in the room
now why does this matter it matters
because
it's not typical that the former
republican president
a former republican president spends
this much time
attacking his own party and certainly
not as much
as he would spend attacking the other
party and trump did go after joe biden
during the speech
it's all the normal stuff he's been
saying about joe biden it barely
you can imagine what it is it's not
particularly uh relevant or
or notable but republicans always attack
democrats the question for the future of
the republican party is whether they
will
eventually come around to deciding we
are in this to defeat democrats or
whether
this split is going to continue and lead
to chaos
and destruction for the party in 2022
and potentially
also in 2024. if they don't resolve this
it has the potential to be
for me delightfully disastrous for
several
election cycles and this would be this
would be a self-inflicted
destruction by the party brought on by
the fact that
for a long time they have been fomenting
non-thinking anti-intellectualism in the
party
okay and understanding the history of
this
matters this trumpian screed over the
weekend
from trump is now many many many layers
removed
of what started during the reagan era
but it did start during the reagan era
and this would sort of be
the just dessert for it if you don't
know the history
a very brief outline is that in the
reagan era
the move of the republican party was
towards
a relatively ignorant but still cohesive
and winning strategy which is let's come
out against welfare and lazy people who
are just
living on the dole we want personal
responsibility let's be for low taxes
let's be for allowing business to
flourish and
it started to be used to provide cover
for racism and xenophobia that was the
80s under reagan
this appealed to some
pseudo-intellectuals and ignorant people
and people who maybe weren't
paying attention to politics previously
and that got us to the early 1990s
in the early 1990s newt gingrich became
speaker of the house
and he really ushered in like if you
imagine a staircase where at the top
is your party implodes into trumpian
delusion
the second step on that staircase um
is the early 90s newt gingrich becomes
speaker of the house and he plays up the
reactionary rhetoric
he takes another step away from policy
and towards nonsense but there's still
a bunch of policy with gingrich stuff
about immigration
stuff about health care there's still
policy but they're taking a step towards
uh the the nonsense that we see today
you then get george w bush
george w bush by virtue of being kind of
dim
and completely amoral and having that
texas cowboy personality
appealed even more to the nonsense over
policy
crowd to the rhetoric over substance
crowd
there was still policy it was pretty
base and rudimentary
lower taxes that's good abortion's bad
gay marriage is bad um you know sending
troops around the world to defend us
under the guise of patriotism that's
good then you get barack obama's
presidency
and that really shifts the scale even
more you have
a real influx and focus on on a ba on
the basis of xenophobia and racism
and the non-thinking side of the
republican party
and then the culmination is you have the
perfect electorate
in the republican primary um
to choose someone like trump
um and then we know you know the rest is
history and so something that was
birthed
by the direction the republican party
chose in the 80s
led to trump even though it bears very
little resemblance to it
can it win them 2022 can it win them
2024.
i have no idea it failed in 2018
and it failed in 2020. in those two
elections the republican party lost the
house
they lost the senate and they had a
president lose the white house and
become a one-term president
maybe it'll work in 2022 but this is
really something they have to figure out
i hope they don't for the betterment of
the country
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress at home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type your sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
they will pair you with a mattress that
will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed
i often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool
it's not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video